All right. Welcome to the to the
DDPS seminar everyone. Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules as
usual. First of all, please mute
yourself during the talk. If you
have immediate questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask.
Otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so
that we will address them in the
q&a session at the end. So
again, today's seminar is open
to external audience, so no
classified discussion is
allowed. Finally, the talk will
be recorded and uploaded to our
YouTube channel. Now please, let
me introduce our speaker. It is
an honor as your host, Professor
Liu Liu, who is currently an
assistant professor in the
Department of statistics and
data science at Yale University.
Before joining Yale, he was a
assistant professor in the
Department of Chemical and
Biomolecular Engineering at the
University of Pennsylvania from
2021 to 2023, and an applied
mathematics instructor in the
Department of Mathematics at MIT
from 2020 to 2001. In 2020, he
obtained his PhD degree in
applied mathematics, master's
degrees in engineering Applied
Mathematics and Computer Science
at Brown University, while he
received his bachelor degrees in
mechanical engineering,
economics and computer science
at Shanghai University in 2013.
His current research lies in
scientific machine learning
including theory, our firms and
software's and its applications
to engineering physical and
biological problems. His broad
research interests focus on
multiscale modeling and high
performance computing for
physical and biological systems.
He has received the 2022 the oh
ye Early Career Award and Tony
Tony Schakowsky Family
Foundation Outstanding
Dissertation Award of Brown
University. Today, he will talk
about new operators with
reliable extrapolation from
multi physics, multi scale and
multi fatality problems, please
enjoy the wonderful talk. Now,
without further ado, let me hand
it over to Lou.
Thank you for the nice
introduction. So, in this talk
at front panel, you may see that
many discuss our original works
of deep neural operators. So, I
will not go to too much the
background introduction, but let
me just give you one page brief
background showing here the
usually when we consider a deep
neural networks, we try to use a
neural network to learn a
mapping of functions. So, from
one finite dimension of the one
tonight if I find that machine D
two. So, this is the accuracy on
opposition error is guaranteed
by the universal approximation
theorem for functions, which was
proved a long time ago in 1989.
So, along this line, many
different methods have been
developed or many different
algorithms have been developed
to achieve will accuracy. For
example, for image
classification, the input image
could be 20 by 20 pixels, which
is 400 dimensions, then output
is a scalar or vector. Also, the
development of physics informed
in our walks, which is also
yours to learn the solution is a
single solution of a PDE which
is the function mapping. But in
this talk, I will copy
understanding the function
learning to operator learning.
So, the operator here I referred
is a mapping from one function
to another function. So instead
of from one final dimension
value to another value, so one
single case, I in calculus, have
an operator either to do to
operator, so if our input is x
t, then our output is the
derivative of x t x prime t. So
this is one simple operator or
we can also consider another
simple operator with integral
for input x t, then we'll
compute the integral of f t with
respect to occur now okay, this
also maps from one function to
another function. But in this
talk, I will mainly consider the
system or PDE saw ODS, the input
could be the boundary condition,
initial condition of force in
terms of the PDE then output
will be the solutions over the
PDE. But a more broadly this
kind of framework can be applied
to other systems biological
system or even social system. So
when we go from functional
learning to operator learning,
then a target question is
whether we can see or learn
operators by using neural
networks. So at first Whether
this exists a similar theory of
universal approximation theory
for functions planning
operational setup. So, let me
first introduce a few notations
here, which were also used in
this talk. So, our protocol we
are learning is denoted by this
square root g and the input a
function is denoted by u, then
output is another function where
they do so, to yield energy you
are both functions LTO is a
function, let's consider why in
a single location or point your
domain of geo then geo Why is
the value of function geo
evaluated at this specific
location? Why is that the answer
to my previous question actually
is true. So, as shown in this
theory here, so, we can prove
that the the new inner works,
so, actually it's very powerful
to approximate nonlinear
operators, but, but definitely
giving you some assumptions. So,
the main assumption is that the
spirit should be compared and
its apology can or should be
continuous giving this too many
assumptions, then, the theorem
is paper shows that for
arbitrary operator G, an
arbitrary input function yield
and a location why they always
exist a neural network in this
form such that the error due to
the current use of energy and
the prediction from the new
network can be arbitrarily small
that n is zero. So, basically
this is a one extension of the
standard approximation theorem
of functions or when our neural
networks for functions extended
to operators. So, I will not go
into details into the theory
part and in this talk I will
mainly consider the methodology
how can we implement the new
network to achieve a good
accuracy and efficiency. So,
when you try to design an analog
I knew and analog to learn
output geo from input a Yo, then
if we consider an analog is to a
black box, let's take a look at
what's the inputs and outputs of
an analog. So, first the our
input must have the input of
function u. So, u is one input
however, the function u is in
the infinite dimensional space,
we cannot directly input this
function into this neural
network when a neural network in
our computers can only take a
finite dimensional input. So,
this the first step is to
convert to have even imagined
space function you to have five
dimension voucher there are
different ways to do this and it
is crucial here I just show you
one simple way let's consider we
have a dense mash up or dense
locations of x 1x two and x m in
the location of the domain of
your data values or function yo
in this locations your x one you
have to ensure you x m can be
used to represent the input file
show your evidence this location
is a dense enough. So, this is
the finite dimensional
approximation of the input then
this can be used as a network
input. Similarly, for the output
of network, still we tried to
predict a function geo instead
of a finite dimensional version.
We can we can do a similar trick
that is the only predate the
function you're at a finite
schedule locations. However,
this in this case, in this talk,
we try to avoid any kind of
discrimination for the operator
function yo. So the way we do
this is as follows. So yeah,
addition to the input function,
yo, we also have another input
of location why that's giving
the input value and why the
output will be the function to
evaluate at this location. Why
this is kind of similar to the
physics IF formula works. So in
physics, the formula works
opinions, the input is the
coordinates, output is a
function of value added to the
specific coordinate. We do
simply say here, y is a
coordinate the output it is
function Geo and this recipient
coordinate why, but this
function depends on the input
function it depends on the input
function. So, this this approach
would be measured free and also
this condition free, it can be
used to unstructured and
arbitrary data locations. So,
this is what is the one age and
other 100 Is that what we
consider PDS is how to compute
the derivatives of an alpha NGO
with respect with y that by
using this approach of here just
the ratio can be directly
computed Biothane automatic
differentiation the same as
pigs. So, this is no
dissertation error. So, this is
inputs and outputs of the neural
network now, let's look at the
network architecture. So, we
could apply and in no
architecture to this kind of
setup, but because here we have
two inputs, so, we can see the
split the entire network into
two or two components. On the
top we have one analog branch
net takes the you as input and
outputs a hidden relative at
both and here we have a NAS
network to terminate takes y as
input and outputs another
kilometre, then we compute the
final output the GU y as a total
potage between these two values
all as shown in equation here.
So, the basic idea is is that
so, g of y is a function of a
you however, is conditioning on
us or is function of y by
conditioning on you that in this
formula here to tk y can be
viewed as a basis function Y and
BK yo basically the coefficients
depends on the yo so in the
coordinate view the Tron net to
learn was optimal basis function
for this machine with PD
temperatures net learns was the
coefficients in front of the
basis function for arbitrary
input.
So, this is a thing called a
test case a testing problem on
your triangle domain with a
notch. So, the PDE is simple,
but in this problem, the
geometry is complex and assuring
the future here. So, we tried to
predict the solution of this PDE
found the boundary conditions
and other training this is a one
case the case over the
prediction. So, we have ground
truth and the prediction over
depot net and the front arrow
here you can see is roughly two
plus wall 2%. So, this is the
first version of vanilla version
of the opponent, but after our
first walk we have developed
many different extensions or
deeper net in order to improve
the accuracy or improve the
efficiency or extend as a
capability to diverse scenarios.
So, as I mentioned, for the
branch net, we have input
function you may need to convert
the input function yield to a
finite dimension approximation
or representation representation
we can apply the evaluation as
we looked at it before or we
could project the input function
v into a basis function, then we
can use the coefficients of the
basis function as the
dissertation also another deep
not extension we have developed
a call a pod deploy net. So as
we as I mentioned, for the
branch net is used to up to
learn what's automobilia
function. However, in scientific
computing, there are many good
measures to compute the basic
function. So, one simple but
good but efficient most
efficient method is called pod
proper orthogonal decomposition.
Then we can further compute the
pod modes from the training data
set, then for the trauma
network. In addition to a
standard analog, we also apply
the pre computed basis from pod.
So, this is a hybrid method of
the new network and the standard
traditional new members so by
using pod so by doing this, so
first of all, instead of
learning instead of learning
everything from scratch by using
a network, we have a good
starting point over the pod
modes. And also we so this will
be increased our tuning
efficiency and also as an end
user we can also achieve higher
accuracy. So this is the same
problem that I see problem. And
in the last column here we show
the performance of the pod
deploy net so compared to the
standard deploy net bios in the
pod patient function, we can
achieve even better accuracy.
So, so, this is the standard
deploy net and if you are the
extension by union pod, but in
all these two examples, as we
can see, we only consider a
single input operator. So, which
means our input a function, it
is a single function in the
previous previous example is a
boundary condition and also in
the theory I have showed the
theory can only be applied to
the input to a single function
input. But if in general or in
many cases, we try to create the
PDE solutions for different
initial condition boundary
condition or for sentence
simultaneously. So, which means
our input is not a single input,
but it is a multiple input
operator. So, specifically,
let's consider our input
expenses in total have owned
bioservices x 1x, two xn or
equivalent we have an input
function it's V one v two and
your VM now, we try to have a
new network takes all these own
functions add input and outputs
a corresponding odd function for
each more PDE solution. So,
before we go to the implement
implementation, or first in
first step, we should always
approve that the neural network
is still universal approximator
in this scenario, so, this one
wouldn't be shown in this in the
paper as shown here. So,
actually in the neural network
can also be used to approximate
multiple input operators. So,
without getting into too much
details, the key idea when we
when we prove the theory is as
follows. So, we construct the
neural network in by showing you
this Euclidean here. So, yeah
addition to a single branch net
we consider we have our own
branch and as their each branch
net takes one function as input
then there is an outputs and
validators will be we have
become our own dimension test,
then for the Tron airwalk
instead of other people pushing
a doubt one dimension validator
deliver output another dimension
tensor, then we compute the
tensor tensor product to compute
the corresponding output. So,
this is okay for the proof by
this tensor a tensor product is
too expensive in practice, then
we can further apply a low rank
tensor approximation to reduce
the cost. So, the further format
is that will predict high
dimensional tensor we also
output for one dimension value
then we have into the own past
one voters, then we compute the
element wise product of all this
matters, then compute the sum of
all the elements in the manager.
So, this is architecture of the
network we call the mu net it
can be viewed as a
straightforward extension of
Drupal net from a single panel
space or sorry from a single
branch net to own branch net. A
simple test case showing here is
a diversion diffusion equation.
So, if you tried to predict the
solution yo from different
initial condition Yujiro and
also different diffusion
coefficients, and here we assume
to defeat acoustic conditions is
also a space dependent. So, this
is one test case of the
training. So, it can shave a
small error. So, this confirms
to you what is the neural net
the meal net is indeed in Warsaw
approximated then we have a
further apart this kind of idea
to more realistic problems
instead of the previous two
simple cases. So, why
application was tested is called
a stage in geoscience geologic
carbon filtration. So, in this
application, so, we inject the
co2 into the under underground,
then whatever you're trying to
do is to predict what's the
saturation or the pressure of
the co2 in the Following our 30
years so, this cobra can be
modeled by the multi phase flow
in the porous media. So, this is
the equation shown here, and
lots of variables. So from this
equation in order to solve it by
using traditional neural
methods, the challenge is that
is too expensive. So, first of
all the problem is multi physics
and the minor scale. And also we
try to solve the problem in a
really large domain. So, your
largest spatial scale and also a
larger temporal scale. So, the
further spatial scale we
consider is from a few 100
meters, or 10 meters to 200
meters by a million meters to a
millimeter in length, and 200
meter depth. And as mentioned in
Chapter pretied, there's the
solution with a PDE for 30
years. So, is that too expensive
of the treasurer measures that
you apply a neural network to
learn a solution for different
inputs. So, it will enable
faster prediction and the for
the for the data set and make
sure you're what's the input and
it was output. So, we have many
different inputs. So, there are
three inputs, there are
functions of the of the spatial
coordinates, so equalling
horizontal permeability,
vertical permeability and
porosity, these are three
functions that any addition to
these three fields, we also have
seven scalar inputs, for example
was the injection rate, the
temperature initial pressure for
it also was the location of
formation. So, given all these
inputs, given all these
conditions, that we can compute
what's corresponding PDE
solution of gas saturation and
also pressure. So, showing here
is just a one specific case. So,
this is injection location, then
the co2 will go from left to
right. So, for this problem, we
can either apply the standard
analog for example, this is just
a 3d problem today in space one
the time then we may apply a
ceiling network, but in 3d
photowall 3d unit or we can play
some other networks for example,
we can learning the free space,
which is the method of FMO. So,
in this paper showing here, so,
they combine the 3d Your net and
a 3d FMO into a single network
in order to achieve good
accuracy of prediction. So, this
is an architecture. So,
initially, this is a one three
layer and also one convolution
layer that was a unit layer.
However, this is again the tweet
extensive of the training and
also prediction by but, but as I
mentioned, we have another tool
Omeo net, if we apply a new
natural to to this case, then we
will have many different branch
nets and a single trauma net for
the branch nets, each branch net
will take a single input,
because we have a group of
inputs as shown here, then we
have a torn edge. So the input
or terminate will be x y and t
or the spatial and temporal
coordinates then our output is a
sin which is just a scalar
basically a solution for the
more saturation at this specific
x y t. In this approach, the
cost is really low instead of
ordering 30 inputs and outputs
outputs is a scalar however, by
using this simple thought pulled
out a merge operation, if I go
to here to all depression as an
uptrend as they are merged
together by a single simple
element wise product and the
sun. So this simple operation is
hard to learn the details
structure in space as shown in
this example here. So it cannot
capture all these details.
Although the accuracy in general
is okay five signs that when we
do a we try to combine the two
approaches together in order to
achieve the prediction accuracy
and also narrow trading
efficiency. So this nanowall
committee Tiny is called a
Fourier meal net. So the general
framework of this network is, is
mu net. So again, a branch and a
trunk. However, for the merge
operation, instead of using a
standard at all for that, we
apply a Fourier layer or a unit
or unit engineer,
by the competitor previous
version of this standard UFO. In
this case, we only need to the
unit and a 2d airfoil. Because
we still have a tonnage of a
Tron that will have a time t as
input, then our output is not a
scalar, but is not a 3d is our
2d solution of the 2d pdf
solution at arbitrary specific
attempt t. So basically, we
still need temporal and spatial
to handle them differently. So
this approach can still achieve
good accuracy as showing in this
four examples here. So in these
four examples, we have different
cases of different patterns of
the solution. So you can see
that our total is 0.99, almost
almost equal to one. But more
importantly, but when we still
keep the good accuracy, we can
have modular screening costs, as
showing in the second table
here. So for you FMO, it has
more than 33 million parameters.
But for the free immune edge, we
only have around 3 million
parameters for the CPU memory,
which can reduce from more than
100 gigabytes to 15 gigabytes
for GPU memory, reduced from 16
gigabytes to six gigabytes. And
the training time can be reduced
from 42 hours to 12 hours. So
it's much more conditional
efficient. And more importantly,
by using this approach, we can
have the prediction even for
unseen time. So let me show you
what I mean here by an unseen
time. So before because we were
trying to predict the solution
for the following 30 years. But
in practice, the data set we
have we have you heard of 24
snapshots in this 30 years. So
would he if we only train to
Nana walk by using just natural
one, snapshot three stamps, or
five, seven, by which we try to
predict for all the snapshots.
If you look at the standard
performance of the UFO, for the
location with the training time
is this good accuracy. But for
the location, for example, for
step two, because there's no
training data set for central
tool down during the production,
the accuracy would be really
low. But for the free immune
net, we are still maintaining a
good accuracy, even for unseen
snapshots. So, it's a good
foundation for us in time. So,
the reason is that so, we put
the term t as a terminal input,
then the network would
automatically satisfy the
property that is the solution
will be continuous over time to
basically obtain a base the
underlying physics are the
continuity over time. So, we can
even use only 25 snapshots for
training. So, this will be very,
very useful when we try to
collect the data set in our real
life, because every single
snapshot data creation is is
expensive. So, this is one
application in geoscience here
then you shoot another
application also in geoscience
to for waveform inversion F wi.
So, in this application, we aim
to infer the subsurface
structure see, to see the
velocity map of the underlying
subsurface structure thrown the
assessment waveform data well
waveform data is p pressure.
Specifically, let's consider we
have a 2d domain to the
subsurface domain. Then, if we
have a source in the location A
then the source will generate a
wave propagates in the in this
domain name you'll have many
different receivers placed on
the surface at this proper
location, top surface here then
You still face this you still
receive us we are received the
wave from the sauce propagates
to through the subsurface for
example for the first picture
shown here, so, this is the our
what the receiver received for
the source aid. So, if we have
source at this location that for
the receivers receivers as a top
jet, we receive these kinds of
signals. So, this is for F
different location and over a
different time, if we have
source at a location B, then
this is the signal received at a
different receivers because we
only have the information at the
surface, we cannot do the
prediction of this velocity map
from a single source. So, in
this case we consider we have
five different sources
allocation ABCD that the task is
that we will try to predict that
will also the map of the
subsurface from these five
signals signal could be a clean
signal or it could be the signal
plus some noise or some missing
traces. And for the for the
equation is an acoustic wave
equation and showing here and
therefore, the source so, as
here we can see that there is a
pot of sauce in the location A
or the Option B or the TNC. So,
it's a pot of sauce and the
generating of by the wavelength
showing in a picture here. And
here the frequency f can control
the shape of the wavelength
steel we applied a network of
the Freer depot net the same
than a walk architecture. So,
after the training, this is a
few different test cases. So,
this is ground truth. So, first
of all we try to see what our
network can have the good
prediction for different source
locations and at different
frequencies of the source. So,
it is the source locations and
the fridges and this is the
three different predictions for
different data inputs, different
frequencies and a different
source locations. So, the
accuracy is good for here i i
try to emphasize the robustness
of the network architecture. So
during the training, all this
data set is clean data set. But
during the testing or production
case, we add a Gaussian noise to
the input of an analog. Now
we'll try to see whether our
nanawall prediction as to be
accurate given the noisy input.
Now, we do not do any fine
tuning or post processing. So
clean data cleaning clean data
set for training, but noisy data
for testing. So, for our test
case, we have four different
patterns of The GroundTruth. But
in this in this example, here I
only show the prediction for s
FVb pattern and a CVA pattern.
So on the left in the Panel B so
this is the different levels of
the noise. So you can see we add
higher and higher noise level to
our input data set to the input
of the network, but for the
production of the fridge
opponent, it is still accurate
is can produce the same pattern
and at the ground truth however,
we compare with other networks
for example, the version that I
have lost it again, these are
two baselines for the F wi
application. There are also
network based approaches.
However, for these two networks,
they cannot tolerate the noise
in the input. So this is another
prediction case for the CVA
ground truth. You're gonna see
even by adding a really high
noise level, we still have good
prediction compared to the
controls, but the prediction
from other networks for
evolutionary almost again is
totally off. So this is one test
case and here this is another
robust test by point of view
consider the source noise.
Variability consider the noise
has as a source has the noise
instead of the input. So, which
means, if you consider during
the producing or testing case,
our data set the test in the
test case
the wavelet is not a perfect
wavelet but it has some noise
for each period here, it has a
really high noise level. So, we
do not see this kind of wavelet
er training data set, but you
will for this case by a pilot
freed up on edge, we are still
have a very good prediction
accuracy compared to controls,
but again for other networks
that accuracy is is bad. Another
robustness test we consider is
the missing traces. So, during
the training, our input is
always clean data, but what if
doing a prediction case or
prediction stage for the input
there are many traces or many
signals they are missing. For
example, in this case, there are
many signals they are just
missing zero by using a free
diplomat, because to have good
accuracy, so, this is the test
case for the CFA in verse NMAP
and STA. So, you can see on
Friday the opponent prediction
for these two cases they do a
very accurate compared to other
networks. So, again, so, we
never seen this kind of yes and
during the training, so they are
all based on their own
explanation. depot net, a
department of radio Panet they
are really the past against all
this noise or missing traces.
Okay, I have a showing several
examples are the former's or
depot net or extensions of
Jupiter net. But in all these
cases, we still need a data set
usually a large data set for
training. However, in practice,
it could be difficult to obtain
a large high fidelity asset.
Now, why dia tools, technology,
the problem is called multi
figure learning. So in modify
their learning, we have two data
sets, one is called high
fidelity asset and the other one
is called low fidelity asset. So
for high fidelity asset, it's
high accurate, but it's my data
is small, but for the low
fidelity is different. So it's
low accuracy, but this data is
large. So, here are two
examples. So on the left, we can
see example with aircraft
design. So we can collect the
data set for them or for
instruments. So, this is
accurate, but is a really
expensive to generate a large to
asset or we can run a
simulations FTM simulations is
less accurate, but we can have a
lot. So, this is another example
of the sea surface temperature
prediction. So, this is the
location of the Boston Harbor.
Now, we try to predict the
temperature in this sea surface.
So the data set that we have
could be the measurement from
all these sensors as shown by
thoughts here. So these are
senses in the seas of bass. So
it's a very accurate, but is is
sparse or we can have the
measurement from the satellite,
it's less accurate or we can
have a lot So, the the mighty
Fidel learning try to integrate
the data set of different levels
together to achieve a good
accuracy. So, we apply the idea
on what the fair learning into
Aquila learning and development
Marty fidelity depot net. So
imagine forget depot net. So,
first of all, we have one depot
net for depot net low. So deeper
deeper than low takes the inputs
for example V or QC then
generates output prediction GL.
So because we assume we have a
large data set or low fidelity,
then this deeper and deeper net
low can be treated well without
any problem. Then the question
is how can we have the
production of high fidelity? So
why idea is that we we aim to
learn the Reggio our question
between low and high fidelity is
Basically we write down the G G
high to high failure prediction
is equal to the low failure
prediction, pass a crash engine,
then we apply network deep on
that high to learn this crash
engine. Also, in many cases,
there is always a high
correlation between low and high
Fidelity's, then we also aim to
lose this correlation by using
component high. So specifically,
for people that are high, we
also in addition to the inputs,
or the function less function v,
we also put the low fidelity
prodution CI low as another
input of a deployment high, then
the jump on a high we will learn
is the correlation between CI
low energy high. So this is a
final architecture and Chris
morning equations. So this is
one test case, or the board's
main transport equation for
nanostructured material. So this
equation is not too complex. But
this is not a single equation,
part of the equation, assistant
of 24,000 Chapala PDS because we
have this index meal, which is
the index of the way of value,
and this is quite Asian in this
bit a bit bosmere transport
ingredients. So it's Livescore
PDS system. And for this case,
we can see that our computer
domain is a square domain. But
in this square domain, we have
five by five squares in this
blue color. And each blue color
can be a poor without a
material. For example, this is
one spreadsheet with all these
locations, they are pause there,
if you solve the big equation in
the geometry, this is a Chris
volume solution. And if you have
different materials with
different location, I'll pause
we have a different solution.
So, we aim to learn the operator
G mapping found the geometry to
the solution, but here we are
not interested in a specific
solution f mu, we are interested
in the heat flux, the GMU the J
as a weighted summation of F mu.
So also this is a complex
geometry. Also, different
training cases have different
geometry, but the point that it
can handle it can be applied
without any modification,
because it's mesh free. So we
have so first we have a low
fidelity set of slides 10,000.
And its accuracy is showing in
the dashed line here. So you can
see the mean square error
compared to the high fidelity
solution with almost 1092. So
it's really a low fidelity
solution. Or if we truly a
diplomat only using high
fidelity solution, we can
increase the dataset size from
10 to a few 1000. If we have
more data set, the error will
decrease. But even if we have
5000 the accuracy is still not
good enough. But by integrating
the low and high the assets
together and using our affiliate
multifidus deponent, they have a
much better accuracy. So one
audio manual, one order of
magnitude smaller than the high
fidelity only, I assure you in
the red line here. So from this
point, we can say it's really
efficient by using mighty
fidelity learning for small
businesses. Okay, I have shown
many cool examples of machine
learning, especially deep on
that however, all these examples
are actually all the machine
most of the machine learning
models, they are limited to
interpolation. But in practice,
we always has explanation. So
the robustness test I shouldn't
be for for the Fw application is
expiration, but is only adding
noises It's not that's why needs
to be kept as patient more than
that. Then how can we hand out
the explanation? So this is the
last part of my talk. Still we
consider the explanation is
operator learning setup. So we
try to learn an operator G with
inputs you are input is V or
politics yo, if you can see the
V is sampled from a space of
Gaussian random Fiat with mean
zero function and covariance
kernel KL
For example, it could be a
squared exponential already a
base boundary kernel showing you
here, in this kernel, this
apparent parameter L. So if L is
large, let's say 1.0, then the
functions in this space, they
are all smooth, showing you the
plot, if owl is more than a
function is, will become more
oxygenated and flush aerated. So
what if we train an airlock by
using all the functions in this
space, there are first
functions. But what if we try to
predict it for the function is
visit conditional as you can
probably walk there intuitively,
the error must be large, because
it's the expiration, we have
never seen this kind of complex
function important during the
training. So let me show you two
specific example of the edge
patient in this optimal learning
setup. So on the left, we have a
simple OD, DOD is equal to V V,
V M to learn the G, mapping from
V, the right hand side of OD to
the solution of OD, then we
generate different trading
assets and different attesting
the asset. So the x axis here is
plot is a quarter last for
training. And the y axis here is
coalition's for testing, that in
this plot your diagonal line to
the training and testing spaces,
they are the same space, the
same correlation class. So our
training equal to our test. So
this is integration. And we know
that we can do well for the
Indonesia. And let's look at the
arbitrage and go over these
domain. So in this domain to
collect less for training, it's
smaller than the calendulas for
testing. So in this case, is
belongs to Azure. However, if we
look at the error here, so the
color is error, you can still
have a small error. So in this
case, we call this as an
aspiration minus, so it's
aspiration, but it's still a
small error, but for the Boolean
triangle of this domain. So, in
this case, the correlation is
for tuning is larger than the
correlation for testing. So
which means between the network
using smooth functions and a
test using now suppose
functions. So in this case, we
have a large arrow. So this is
expectation, VM to address as
tribulation paths are about to
unfold, especially miners. So in
this case, it means the trains
network using complex functions,
but a test using smooth
functions, so the network can
handle it. The same phenomena,
we have observed the many other
examples, for example, defeater
you actually recursion and many
more. Okay, we have to address
this issue of ash patient our
past. But before we designed the
algorithm, so let's first in the
first step, let's try to
quantify the complexity of an
equation. So, if we do we have
two spaces F two quadrillion
fields a form space and F F two
space. So, we try to measure the
distance between these two
spaces. So, one way to do to
measure this is by using a W two
metric actually the current
here. So, back here, I what I
tried to show is that the W
metric cannot be only used to
measure the distance between
these two spaces, it can also be
used to quantify or to indicate
the complexity of attribution
again for the OD example, we are
testing and four different space
of a compatible train training.
And in this plot, so, the x axis
is the WHO distance between the
training space and the testing
space, the y axis is the ash ash
patient error. So, you can see
the log log scale the expedition
error error as a linear scaling
versus W distance. So, which
means we can use Tableau to
distance to infer or to indicate
how the complexity of the edge
patient for a new input. Then
based on this, we design this a
framework of flowchart for
reliable explanation. So first
step is do we have SSTO We have
a pre trained deployment, or
predefined data set we're going
to do now is pre training.
Therefore a new input input
function V. The first use apply
our pre trained upon that do the
prediction. Let's say I'll
provision your tiada then we can
quantify whether this huge
theater or whether this input
function v belongs to
interpolation, or attribution
manners or exploration past. If
is interpolation or
extrapolation miners, then we
know, we can have a good
accuracy by directly returning
to a prediction of your tiara.
If ash patient minus a plus,
then the Utah would have a large
error, then we have to improve
or Colorado or Utah, but we
can't wait about a year to do
this will require some
additional information. So the
additional information through
some physics or some new data
set. So the field is clear,
usually I refer is the governing
equations. So if we have the
county equation, then we can do
the fine tuning over the pre
trainer report net in order to
prove improve accuracy. If it's
a new data set, first of all,
the new data set definitely is
small, right if you have already
a large asset for our for
Newspace, then we can target the
opponent for that. So, if we
assume we have we only have a
small asset for the for new
cases, then we can still do fine
tuning by using the new spouse
the asset or we can also apply
the multi fidelity idea I have
discussed. So our producer, your
Ciana, although is less
accurate, but it can be your
channel for arbitrary input and
arbitrary location. And a new
data set is more police accurate
event which is can be viewed as
high fidelity, VA primary fear
learning so integrated to so in
our paper, we have developed
many different versions of how
do we do the fine tuning How are
how we perform the Marty Fidel
learning. So have you noticed
here, there are many different
approaches. But let's look at
one example of this global
climate change. So GSR data set
of the daily surface, air
temperature, TX and also
pressure px from the ES 1950 to
2021. And this is one example of
the temperature and the pressure
of the earth filthiest on the
date of January 1 2021. And we
aim to learn ophthalmology
mapping from the temperature to
the pressure. However, we only
train our Diplomat using the
data set from 1950 to 1955,
which is the first five years
for training, then we'll try to
do the prediction for all the
remaining years. And he's a
pilot here in SC four liter Yes,
we will have a larger aspiration
error. Because we have a global
climate change pattern or the
correlation between temperature
and pressure. They are not
fixed. They change over time.
Okay, then you also improve the
prediction accuracy, let's say
for this date, January 1 2021.
Let's consider we have one we
have extra the asset at 100
Weather locations I assure you
all the pie the black dots here
so we have 100 spots
measurements on the Earth's
surface, then by using this
actual measurement, you can
improve the accuracy of our
prediction because this is a
final error, it's been turned
off of all areas is below 0.7%.
It is it what I tried to present
today, so basically we have
developed a family of deponents
strategy, cornet mill net, a
purely deployment of 3d Point
edge, and many different other
versions
on and we have applied our
network to many, many different
applications multiphysics
multiscale applications. I
didn't present all of them, but
you can funded some references
here and also in our website. So
on the last page, I let me
briefly introduce our software
called defense D. So this is
open source software for
scientific and machine learning
and all the physics informed
learning. It implements many
different methods. For example,
all the deep corners are
different versions, I am
presented a and other physicists
informed nanowalls and some
other networks. Nowadays, we
have a more than 50 contributors
around the world, adding a
frequent delay to contribute new
features and a new code to the
library. And he can get up Yeah,
free, feel free to use the
library, or modify elaborate to
implement a new method. With
that, thank you very much for
your attention. Yeah, thanks.
Thanks for the wonderful talk do
so now we'll have the q&a
section. Oh, Harry, US in the
early stage. Um, so he asked us
the theory talking about how
many there are parameters we
need to use to successfully
approximate the operator?
Yeah, that's a cool question. So
in the theory here, and also in
the second theory, I should have
here it's only a theory of the
universe or possible
approximation. So which means
the guarantee is there exists an
outcome, that good enough party
does not provide us more
information, for example, what
should what an outsider should
be? But you know, another paper,
at least in the end. In this
paper, we did more analysis over
the narrower size. For example,
if we try to achieve if some
error was generic, essentially,
if you're interested in
different you can refer to this
at this paper. However, this
paper still has a limitation, we
only consider a very specific a
few rpds of form more complex
PDS is the downside is too
annoying.
Okay. So Raven, ask, what are
the branch and chunkiness inputs
respectively for the PD examples
like the dassie and the
affection diffusion
problems? Yes. So for the
network showing here, for the
terminate the inputs is the
coordinates is the same as
pings. So for example, the
spatial coordinate x y g, if a
temporal coordinate energy for
the branch net, the input is the
specific condition or the PDE,
you're trying to solve, for
example, in this case, for the
trauma net, the input is
boundary condition. Then for
other cases, for example, in
this innovation diffusion case,
the input is a diffusion
coefficient, R DX, and also
initial condition your Gen X.
C, so I don't see any, any more
questions, maybe I can ask one
more, or the extrapolation part.
So on page 39.
So
I see you use this additional
information to correct the
original tibone as a preventable
net output. So you use kind of
like physics and new data. So
what kind of physics? Are you? I
mean, assuming like in the
complicated example, that you
show the climate change? So are
you assuming full physics?
Exactly. I mean, you know,
everything about the PDF and
everything about the domain?
Oh, yeah, good question. You
know, people, what they did is
we assume we know the PDS for
this example. In this example of
it to know those three things.
So we only test the case of a
new data set, because it's the
fetus is too complex, as is
unknown. I see. Nearby in our
other cases, your favorite TV
shows, if we know the physics
right now is now a distorted
version. And then you can play
it for fine tuning. See?
So if there are no more
questions, let's thank you again
for sharing his excellent
research with us. Thank you